hey everybody it's Mike frieder with
on-call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we're talking about CMC
control
ia.l2-3.5.4 employ replay resistant
authentication mechanisms for network
access to privileged and non-privileged
accounts
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all the cmmc
defars and nist SP 800171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you've found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform into your
company's on-call compliance Hero Let's
jump into it
cmmccontrolia.l2-3.5.4 employ replay
resistant authentication mechanisms for
network access to privileged and
non-privileged accounts what's an
instant replay just kidding what is
replay resistant it essentially means
that if someone captured your keystrokes
via a key logger they would be able that
they would not be able to play back your
keystrokes and get into your system how
do you do that there are a lot of
different ways to do this but primarily
you're looking at the concept of
implementing a rolling key or
multi-factor authentication type of
solution here's an example if you enter
your username and password and that's it
that doesn't change so someone capturing
and replaying your keystrokes could get
in however if you have a three-part
sign-in with a username a password and
an MFA key or token which rolls over
every few seconds replaying that
combination will not work to Grant
access pretty cool if you ask me but hey
I don't actually count because I don't
make the rules all right let's look at
what hey you know what this is cool the
assessor is only looking for like one
thing determine if replay resistant
authentication mechanisms are
implemented for network account access
to privilege and non-progos accounts now
what's the answer this it's simpler than
you think MFA is implemented for all
accounts able to access cui right so
same answer as last control so you don't
really have to actually do anything
unique but what you do need to know is
that MFA really is sort of your golden
ticket to stopping replay attacks pretty
cool if you ask me
and on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who've had
this DeForest nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in your laps
like a seagull on a sunny day and we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps gray areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance as your
secret weapon to land more Defense work
with higher profit margins now that's
what becoming an on-call compliance hero
can do for you
if you're looking for more help getting
compliant our compliance experts are
always on call for you visit
cmmcc-complianceecrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out here for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance starts
roll it out a 10x compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
and us in the comments below to let us
know what you'd like to know more about
when it comes to information security
and compliance and I'll see you on the
next one
[Music]
okay